bonsoir j'ai failli être distrait dans
la préparation du quatrième débat des
européennes qui opposera ce soir bernard
kouchner à philippe de villiers bonsoir
messieurs j'ai failli être distrait
parce que je ne voulais pas manquer le
superbe match de tennis que mary pierce
a offert aux téléspectateurs de france 2
cet après midi à roland garros la
française s'est qualifiée pour la finale
du tournoi en battant steffi graf numéro
un mondial et c'est la première fois
depuis 1967
depuis françoise durr qu'une française
jouera en finale de ce tournoi avant de
retrouver mary pierce en direct de
roland garros
suivons les images et le résumé du match
avec françois brabant ça c'est déjà très
toujours qu'elle y croit et seulement 13
secondes que ça lui paraît incroyable
mary pierce a gagné mary pierce est en
finale de roland garros
madame pire ce maire en est tout
retourné steffi graf
aussi cette demi-finale ça devait être
un souffle d'air frais sur le tennis
féminin
mais dès le début c'est une véritable
tempête
3 0 puis 5 2 mary pierce n'a pas l'air
tendu sa première balle de set et la
botte
mais une autre tempête plus humide celle
là s'en mêle au plus mauvais moment
pense-t-on marie mènent alors 3 jeux à 2
son élan et coupez pas pour longtemps
car la pluie n'a rien changé
marie est concentré steffy est débordé
pas le temps pour steffi graf de laisser
passer l'orage en 1h17 seulement et une
seule balle de match ils l'emportent 6 2
6 2 marie la française sort la tenante
du titre
maintenant il faut lui succéder samedi
en gagnant la finale